anfang an wenn ihr sagt sich einfallen
[Musik]
die c klasse
die gruppe von arques was man alles
nicht weiß ich habe mir gebracht die
gerade das ist zu jung
die gerne repräsentiert noch mal war das
gibt's nur kurz
herzlich willkommen bei der undercover
am besten in die knie gehen
[Gelächter]
euro schwere die militärpolizisten mit
die militärprozesse die militär die
frauen oder männer hatte bei der polizei
die frauen und männer die bei der
militärpolizei arbeiten sind vielfach
perfekt ausgebildete personenschützer
bedeutet sie haben es nicht nur von man
zum analyse von frau zu frau drauf sie
haben das ist dass du dich herstellt und
loslassen
und ich glaube da sehen sie nicht
schlägst du ein ja am boden gegangen und
wollten erst kommt da kommt er zu mir
kommen oder wenn es irgendjemand sagt
das machen wir nochmal was noch kommt
ist der erste übung ist einfach froh
dass jetzt so zugerichtet nicht nur
darum steht und wir sind halt in allen
städten typ ich bin der böse aber ich
bin gar nicht so böse ich bin in
wirklichkeit doch total brav dabei haben
wir können wir in dieser dose einfach
als gegeben
aber wenn er sich dann werd ich nicht
noch mehr wert
er ist auch jemand in die relegation
kann man überall drauf stecken oder auch
wenn das nicht so wäre wäre
[Musik]
erstens zweitens ich bin happy für alle
möglichen zuerst wird lachen mich jetzt
mehr ausrichten
ich kann spielen was du denkst
sensationell
bis hier her eigentlich mein aufsager ja
dahinter jetzt ein bissel aus aber das
war einfach der name um mit diesen job
herzlich willkommen zu einer lustigen
[Musik]
dass robert das erste mal das erste mal
die militärpolizei bin ich begegnet dem
jahre schnee militärpolizei kommt jetzt
zum militär selbstverteidigungskurs
mittel wie das ist zum beispiel
polizistin unseren polizisten gibt
sie ist von den polizisten militärs der
selbstverteidigungskurs obwohl ich nur
knapp
das verbrechen ist schlechter musik
fischmarkt oder eben würde
[Musik]
ja gott sei dank - es gibt ja auch